[Music]
how
is aretha doing
all right just all right
singing is sacre and you shouldn't do it
just because somebody wants you to
what's most important is that you are
treated with dignity and respect
your specialty you have a talent they
call
genius think about what you're trying to
do to me
how old is she she's 10 but her voice is
going on 30 huh
how many albums have you had four and no
hits
i need you to focus and avoid frivolous
distractions
honey find the songs that move you until
you do that
you ain't going nowhere
i need a change i want to sing what i
want to sing
[Music]
okay
[Music]
you really like it we love
[Music]
by this new chick named aretha franklin
franklin you're not about to mess this
up for me
ladies and gentlemen mr rita franklin
look at that this song goes out the
morning to
anyone who's ever felt mistreated
you need to take a break i know how to
run my business
have you lost your mind maybe i found it
i believe i have the chills
she's a miracle
[Music]
you